[Music]
all right people this is my last direct
message of 2017 so hopefully I'll make
it a good one last week we put up five
shows in five days for Ruben Report
YouTube week this week we've gotten I
sit down with former National Public
Radio CEO Ken Stern and next week we'll
be highlighting some of my favorite
episodes of the year today's direct
message is going to be quicken to the
point with the incredible gratitude and
a humble heart I want to thank all of
you who helped make 2017 such a
memorable year here at the Rubin report
the ride to get here from 12 years of
stand-up comedy in New York City to my
pop culture radio show at Sirius XM to
hosting on The Young Turks to joining my
friend and mentor Larry King on Ora TV
and finally to this independent show
funded by you has been a long and
winding journey one which I wouldn't
trade in for anything it's only been a
year and a half since we made the move
to independence and as some of you have
heard me say the night before we
launched on patreon I literally thought
that my career as well as the careers of
my team might actually be over
fortunately within hours of launching we
quickly realized that not only was it
not over but we were just at the
beginning in the 18 months since then I
bought a home in which we built this
totally professional home studio we
expanded the team behind the scenes the
show absolutely exploded with almost
400,000 new subscribers and most
importantly we've continued to have
honest civil conversation that hopefully
has left you feeling a little more
enlightened and a lot less alone this
year we did an on-location shoot with
ayaan Hirsi Ali I interviewed Richard
Dawkins in front of a live studio
audience in New York City we helped put
important voices fighting for academic
freedom on the map like Jordan Petersen
Brett Weinstein and Lindsay Shepherd we
hosted a conversation on religion and
morality with Dennis Prager and Michael
Shermer we introduced you to incredible
voices fighting for liberalism like
Yasmin Muhammad and Lube de Achmed we
also introduced you to some previous
guests like Peter bagozzi and Eric
Weinstein and GAD said all of whom who
are great guests but more importantly
have become great friends of mine as
well and of course we also hosted the
infamous debate between
Blair White and Candace Owens which got
me trending on Twitter for the first
time in my life hashtag save Dave your
support also allowed me to take some
time off in August to work on my book
and take 30 truly life-changing days off
the grid in an age when we never get off
our devices when we're slammed with news
about terrorism right after we scroll
past a cat video and a picture of your
high school friends kid you guys gave me
the greatest gift I could possibly ask
for a little time to reset and to
rejuvenate and in exchange for you
giving me some of that precious time we
made sure to have all new shows for you
throughout August ready to roll while we
were gone I've got a long list of people
to thank for making everything happen
here but I have to give personal
shoutouts to David - a mirror - Alexis -
Talia and even - Emma there's an
incredible amount of work that goes into
producing these shows and the only
reason that it looks so easy is because
of the team that I have making it look
just that way I also want to give a
special shout out to those of you who
provide us with monthly support on
patreon and on PayPal or who have done
one-time donations via Bitcoin your
support not only keeps us independent
but has given me the luxury of saying no
to several big-money offers this year as
long as that support remains I see no
reason to change that and I promise that
I will do my best to make sure that your
continued support is well worth it and
of course thanks to all of you who watch
share and like these videos we've never
put a dollar into YouTube ads but the
show continues to grow because you
helped it do so the emails that I get
from you saying how you're putting the
ideas we discuss your into action or
changing what you believe because of
something you've heard or just talking
to people in a new way because of the
tone we've set here is incredibly
inspiring and I'm sorry if I don't write
everyone back immediately trust me I'm
trying so thank you thank you and thank
you this time of year is when we give
thanks and show gratitude and it's all
of you who have given me so much to be
thankful and grateful for I look forward
to kicking off 2018 with you soon enough
but in the meantime Merry Christmas
Happy Hanukkah happy New Year and may
the force be with you
[Music]
joining me today is the former CEO of
National Public Radio and the author of
Republican like me how I left the
liberal bubble and learn to love the
right kenster and welcome to the Rubin
report thanks Dave thanks for having me
on the show
you left the liberal bubble and have
survived I did you're a survivor so live
on 94 percent Democratic ninety-four
percent Democratic Ward in Washington
you see 100% Democratic household
increasingly concerned about this we may
kick you out of the house so under
debate and my 10 year old son booed my
first television appearance when the
book came out and I've been crease ly
concerned about sort of the polarization
how much we hate the other side often
without really knowing the other side so
I decided I'd spend I'd do something
about it for myself
recognizing I am in a bubble like all of
us are I wanted to spend time as much as
I can
it could trying to understand things
from some things from the someone else's
point of view and that's been a year
traveling the country communing with
conservatives with Republicans really
trying to see things from their point of
view
yeah and that did survive so yeah or we
get well you've survived so far let's
see it let's see how this hour okay and
there's a lot that I want to talk to you
about because even the use of the word
liberal in the subtitle I think is
interesting because I always talk about
the difference between the left and
liberalism and and a few other things
but first let's just find out a little
bit about your your back story what we
are doing that led you to be the the CEO
of NPR so I've spent a good part of my
career in media spent on some
international broadcasting Voice of
America and joined NPR in 1999 first as
chief operating officer and then
eventually became CEO and was there
during it for about a decade have spent
time in almost all the unpopular
professions there are law politics and
media so
thank you from EDC all right so the
whole thing here yeah so there's there's
a lot to dislike about my background
parently for most of the country tell me
a little bit about just the NPR machine
I know half my audience the my audience
that leans right is probably hearing NPR
and they're going oh I like this guy
because he left the bubble butt but NPR
like raises some flags for them and then
my audience on the left is going NPR
they're the they're the the new Bible of
truth and all that tell me a little bit
about just the ecosystem of NPR so
impera interesting place it is a really
collective of public radio stations from
around the country so NPR is a company
which I ran for for a number of years of
journalists and similar people it's
essentially a news organization but it
is connect to do 500 public radio
stations around the country so it's
unique in the sense that you know most
of its reporters are located Washington
see in similar places but you can go to
virtually any community around the
country the wilds of Alaska you'll find
public radio stations which I think
makes it sort of a unique place yeah do
they have any other connection the radio
stations other than that they fall under
the NPR well there are there all part of
the nut NPR they're all part of the
public radio system and the thing that
often people key on is that they are not
through NPR through the corporation
public broadcasting the recipients of
various federal funds support their
operations yeah what does it say that if
we were to look at all of these radio
stations that I would guess that
probably every single one of them leans
left yet they're funded by the
government so this isn't this isn't a
nonpartisan radio operation really right
yeah so I've made myself somewhat
unpopular in public radio over the last
few months by saying two things which I
think you can hold in your head at the
same time I actually have a lot of
admiration for virtually all the
reporters I know at NPR and poetry or
stations they try to do tell stories
from both sides they're dedicated to the
craft of journalism sometimes I think
they are often even to almost metronome
like and here's one point of view here's
another and so I think it is appropriate
to acknowledge that they are serious
journalism doing journalists trying to
be balanced and fair to appropriate a
slogan from Fox right I think the
challenge that I raised with emoji made
me unpopular is they all probably not
offer many of them come from the same
these are self-perpetuating
organizations they hire people who are
like them who tend to think like them
came from similar backgrounds all
problem many of them I think if you took
our census of them you'd find very few
vote for Donald Trump right it's funny I
can see how carefully you're trying to
be with your words that you don't want
to say all and of course you don't mean
every employee there but probably the
vast vast majority if not 90% or more
are progressives I think is basically
what you're trying I think that a
probably right and so I mean so I think
the challenge is not that they're
progressives but there is a consequence
of group think about what stories are
important what what policies are right
and wrong what what voices should be on
the air and I think that's a real
challenge for a place like NPR and
really for mainstream media as a whole
you know it's what I said to the folks
at NPR was you know they would never
think of covering racial issues only
with white males no matter how good
those white males are and really should
be the same with with politics they
should shouldn't cover it only with
people who largely come from a
progressive background no matter how
dead hear the craft of journalism there
what kind of racial they should be made
where well it doesn't matter I just mean
any sort of you know if they wanted to
cover you know if they had a beat on
race in America right they would not
only have they wouldn't just wouldn't
have whites on it white males only on
and they shouldn't it shouldn't cover
gender issues on okay with men I mean I
think you need to have people of
different backgrounds and different
ideas to have the right type of creative
tension that a newsroom needs right
you're not saying exclude those people
you're saying there's no of course not
all right I'm all for white male last I
checked yeah you know they it's it's
it's that you need to have divert not
only diversity of gender and race in in
newsroom you have to diversity of ideas
and backgrounds yeah so where were your
politics so you started there in 99 were
you a hardcore lefty were you a centrist
yeah liberal there I don't think a
hardcore person to write the book I'd
and take the experience but I spent time
to democratic politics on the real life
for Bill Clinton I think you know I
think I say in the book my voted
straight Democratic ticket except for I
think I probably voted against Barry and
Barry and there's various quest to be
there for life and that's about it so
the crack arrest was too much for you
that's where you drew the line with
Marion Barry yes that's right that's
right
yeah so when did you sort of start
realizing that there was this
ideological lockdown on alternative
opinions there you mean it so I think
there's an alternative lockdown and
ideas generally yes does not make this
about NPR one place because I think
that's unfair because what has happened
in this country is we've all become in
our own bubbles liberals conservatives
and it's it's a product of a number of
different things that's going on it's
really quite extraordinary it's we now
choose where we live based upon
political ideology and try to find
homogeneous neighborhoods politically
homogeneous neighborhoods it didn't
exist before our political parties are
increasingly political homogeneous
they're no such thing as conservative
Democrats or liberal Republicans anymore
they don't have homes yeah where's the
dog Democrats go they guys that I would
love to be voted right they died I mean
the Blue Dog caucus was quite important
15 years ago now doesn't exist anymore
there is no Democrat who is more
conservative than the than the most
liberal Republican and vice versa
they're the Venn diagram does not meet
anymore in the Congress and now we've
our all of our own media right so
conservatives Gillison Fox or any other
or Rush or any other place Democrats had
liberals and progressives have plenty of
choices that fit their own and it's a
credibly destructive and it means we're
all increasing their own bubble and when
that happens it's not that we actually
begin to disagree more becomes easy just
easy to demonize the other side when you
don't know them well you don't hear from
them when you don't dialogue with them
it's really easy to hate each other and
that's what's happened this country we
really hate the other side in ways that
are very different than 15 years ago
well I think that's why I do this show
and why you wrote this book yeah but
before we get out of the fully the the
radio part yeah you mentioned Rush why
does it seem
that right-wing radio so rush and Glenn
Beck and Michael Savage and the list
goes on and on seems to be commercially
viable gets tons of listens and all that
and left-wing radio it simply doesn't
work outside of what's funded really by
the government so Air America was a
catastrophe
right right example I don't have a good
answer that so let's let me admit up
front I don't think it's good answer
I'll tell you what conservatives will
say they will say I don't think this is
either I think it's a little bit of
truth and a little bit of falsehood in
is what liberals find a home a place
like the New York Times and NPR they're
comfortable with him there their needs
are met and they'll say that Rush and
others sessile because conservative
needs are not met in mainstream media
yeah
and that's you know I'm not gonna make
it equivalency between left and right I
think that's a false equivalency in
terms of media and how they operate but
it is clearly true when you look at the
the psychographics of the of the readers
and your times or the listeners NPR they
come primarily from the left yeah when
you hear people on the right it's
usually people on the right say well why
are we funding NPR I mean why is the
government and even funding public radio
at all at this point and especially if
there is an ideological bent to it how
do you respond yeah again I don't want
to let's not take this too far because
that ideological bent is it is right in
sort of an unconscious way a
subconscious way it doesn't have I think
no one sits at NPR ordinary we didn't
used to and says you know let's tell one
side of the story and not the other yeah
I suspect that's actually not quite true
I mean I think they're in their bubble
as you talked about here so much that I
don't know that they're consciously
doing it but they've sort of decided
what yeah I think it's everything I
think it's a fair criticism right but
there's a difference I mean there's a
very significant difference in how
mainstream media works and conservative
media works unless there's new knowledge
without sort of attributing anything
good or bad to it and some knowledge
that they come from a different place
and a different sort of journalistic
ethic you know a public fraud funding
for broadcast public broadcasting is an
artifact of a different era you know
they they they started in 1970
when there was no three networks and
there were just no real alternatives to
those three networks and a handful of
newspapers and it was really important
that the government as they do in
England in a lot of other places support
the public radio and public televsion
and they exist I'm probably true that if
if Paul grade and Public Television did
exist no one would create it now because
there's so many different outlets the
reason is I think it's interesting
though to actually explore the reason
why public broadcasting funding still
exists it's not because of NPR and PBS
it's because of the local stations the
people who you know don't bang on NPR
and PBS but those at least in my day the
people who actually stood up for public
broadcasting and when it came to
probation time it was Ted Stevens as
conservative a senator you ever get from
Alaska because he didn't really care for
NPR more psp2 but he loved Alaska
problem casting and he knew that that
was Alexia lifeline lifeline brought
service to parts of Alaska that didn't
get content local news and others and
that's why I think it still gets pokes
but spoke support not because of like or
dislike for the National content
providers that's interesting I don't
know too much about Ted Stevens
specifically but I wonder was he
fighting would he been okay with well
let let's the state fund it then you
know not instead of the federal
government or is this all funded I
assume is it is a partnership partly
with the states with put ups it
so public broadcasting is complicated
but yeah state we don't have to go to do
you think it's interesting
relative to so many not all many
broadcasting stations get significant
support from local jurisdictions whether
it's a state or a municipality
yeah so even though he probably wasn't
thrilled with what they were putting on
air he just wanted some of the federal
funds that helped allow it cuz he liked
it for his state's purposes yeah he knew
it was a lifeline service to Alaska and
Wyoming and other places like that they
don't have major media markets that's
really who and that's where the money
goes is to those stations right it's
interesting because the world has
changed so much obvious so 1970 and the
idea that the government I mean
me and I get access to me streets great
and I was just watching it with my niece
a couple weeks ago but the idea that the
government is funding any of these ways
that we get media now it seems very
archaic to where we are in 2017 it is
you know the interesting to think about
and we could spend the whole hour
talking about it and hope we don't get
my book yeah we'll get there but if
federal funding went away tomorrow on
the radio side I know much more about
rare than television
NPR Altima would be fine many of the
stations in big cities would be fine
it's actually the rural stations that
would collapse mm-hmm
and that's why you know I think there is
that support for public broadcasting
funding as it goes forward yeah just
generally speaking do you think that if
funding was slowed down or cut or
whatever that wouldn't private people
that feel that this is important jump in
on that I mean that's one of the themes
that I talked about here a lot about how
much should the government do and if the
government stopped doing so much maybe
if these things are vital and important
that private people would and they
didn't take on some of the burden that
public radio I think principal support I
mean 10 years out of date so at least
when I was there the principal revenue
came from listeners like you yeah that's
where the the largest source of revenue
comes from so as the host of the PBS
fundraiser in New York City yeah in
Manhattan right many years ago I gave
away some totes and all that did it for
free yeah no yeah so again I think
wouldn't in New York WNYC would be fine
they probably hate me for saying this
but I don't know that poll asked a
public radio would be fine because the
amount of people to give them money
pretty pretty low I mean do you have a
number of people and the wealth
available to tap is is very different
there yeah it's just an interesting
dilemma because I could see some
valuable stations in these local markets
these small markets that there's worth
to them and then on the other hand it's
like why should we be funding all of
these things if they can't just exist on
their own it's just an interesting
philosophical
because it's one those issues which I
think if conservatives talk to conserve
is about and liberals talk to liberals
about they come to very different points
of view yeah if you actually talk to
people who know and put people together
actually realize it's actually a fairly
complicated nuanced issue that has no
sort of obvious right or wrong answer
yeah it's actually true when you go out
and talk to people about issues people
actually you know in social media
they're angry and mad but no life
actually pretty moderate and that's one
of the things I discovered in my year
traveling the country yeah well people
are always there seemingly worst online
and snappiest and very rarely do that
you know when you're standing across
somebody or sitting across somebody just
like this so let's talk about the word
liberal for a second the subtitle is how
I left the liberal bubble and learn to
love the right yeah
what does liberal mean to you so I think
that's a catch-all phrase for
progressive Democrat in some type of
gross way describe Democrats progressive
people of the left I don't mean
necessarily classical liberal as you
might be thinking of it yeah has it
meant because I think today it means
it's the catch-all for I know it's a
very portion of the spectrum yeah it's
unfortunate for me because I've tried
really hard to show people that if
you're a classical liberal and you
believe in the individual and live and
let live that actually that is virtually
nothing to do with progressives but even
even some of my allies now who are on
the right well we say liberal liberal
liberal and of my guys let's separate
from left but yeah yeah I don't know if
I gave you that careful thought of the
term I mean I think it's a catch-all for
the people whose environment I was
shared yeah well I lived with the people
I worked with the people who ran the
medialization is that I used yeah did
you find those people to actually be
liberal though I know this is a little
bit about the definition of the words
but did you find that they really at
their heart were liberal I mean that
they really were tolerant and
understanding and liberalism in its best
sense good god no and I think this gets
us to where the book is yeah I think the
thing that's worried me obviously two
things one of which is I think that's
share we're increasingly intolerant of
anyone who disagrees with us it's a
strong airily so and it is angered me a
little bit sore wounding me personally
because I've always thought of I mean
like you thought of liberals one of the
tenets of modern liberalism is tolerance
of respect of different perspectives and
belief that really we need
a diversity of ideas and there is value
in different ideas and value in
listening and engaging that is not a
value of modern American politics as we
know it and that is her wounds me
personally one of the things that led me
to this book yeah do you remember a
moment when you started seeing that more
amongst your kind so to speak so I'll
tell you story no not particularly I
mean I think there are lots in us but
I'll tell you a story that's got beyond
going in the book yeah which is a story
of my neighbor and Washington DC I live
in this nice neighborhood called Mount
Pleasant 94% democratic award the the
Green Party candidate polled Donald
Trump in the last election and you know
it's a nice diverse neighborhood we
value our diversity but we don't it's
always been obvious we make jokes about
we'd never really valued political
diversity obviously so but it really hit
home to me on something called the
Hobart Street pledge that's the name of
the street I live in it's a very got a
lot team spirit on Hobart Street we have
lots of block parties we close the
street a Halloween and our biggest block
party is called porch fest and has a
parade and every year it starts with the
Hobart Street pledge I always love the
idea of the Hobart Street pledge to the
kids sort of pledge allegiance to Hobart
Street Northwest right and change every
year and one year at went I pledge
allegiance to Hobart Street Northwest
yada-yada-yada everyone is welcome on
Hobart Street white white or black gay
or straight man or woman everyone but
Republicans and it was a joke but it
wasn't a joke and I wrote a mediocre
article for the Atlantic about it but it
really got me thinking about how have we
come to a place where we can value
diversity but not viewpoint diversity
and that's I think where we are as a
country and let's say you know what I'm
not all that different I have the same
sort of prejudice against the other side
let me test that in some interesting
ways so how did you start testing that
so I you know so so it's a challenge
like okay how do you actually see things
from the other point of view so over a
course of year I did so tons of
different things that went to Trump
rallies and spent
Tea Party meetings and went pig hunting
in Texas spent more time than the rest
of my life combined in church mostly
Evangel evangelical churches I got
adopted by a Assembly of God
congregation in Fredericksburg Virginia
I went you know spent time working class
bars in Youngstown Ohio and went to coal
mining country went in a tour I've
thought of all the places I thought I
should hate like Liberty University and
you know on hunting trips and gun shows
and Texas and really found out I didn't
hate them and they didn't hate me and
that actually you know we disagreed on a
lot of things with the people I met but
eight things out of ten we probably saw
eye to eye on whether they actually
talking and that was a real lesson work
she's surprisingly moderate people you
just wouldn't know it from the the media
environment we all live in so what's it
like to show up in these places how'd
you do it did you just walk into a
church and go guys um I'm here to make
sure I don't hate ya what's going on
here I did it's exactly what I did so
I'm a couple interesting experiences I
went to a evangelical Jamboree for a
Jamboree for evangelical youths 15,000
called Urbana in in a football stadium
in st. Louis I managed to get an
invitation to that and spent two days
listening kids talk about you know their
the issues that I want talking about
abortion and gay rights but they want to
talk about I want to talk about black
lives matter they want to talk about
refugees how to help them not how to
keep them out and so a little bit of a
preconception destroying experience and
then I went to churches so I emailed
pastor Steve
so actually tell you how I ended up with
the pastor seat so I had a sort of a a
rabbi that's maybe not the right term
when he talked about evangelicals in the
evangelical community guy a professor at
Washington University Law School named
John and Naz ooh and he said I told him
I went to one of the big ventricle mega
churches that I sort of proudly told him
that he said well you know that's great
but you need to go to an evangelist
Emily of God Church you know with 50
members to really see the real or heart
of evangelicalism like what the hell I'm
gonna find that I live in Washington DC
and I googled evangelical churches
Washington see someone you know
in sort of desperation hmm it turned out
there were like a hundred congregations
within 50 miles and no idea about it so
I randomly picked one had had a service
time that appealed to me and emailed
pastor Steve and said I write a book I'd
like to come was a little hesitant but
you know he opens his door to everyone
and I probably went down there half a
dozen times in Fredericksburg Virginia
and essentially pastor Steve and I
actually have almost the same sort of
biography in some ways we were the same
age were born the same area had very
different paths in life but we actually
both have a wife and one son who's this
happens to be the same age we had a lot
in common very different thoughts in
life and what's important but a lot in
common you know when I think of pastor
Steve I think of you know someone who I
really admire and you know when people
all d'être everyone the right as
deplorable
I think a pastor Steve and a lot of
other people I met and I know that
description is just flat wrong yeah so
you go to the churches now were you just
sort of watching from the back or did
you actually be on the pastor I mean did
you start interviewing people did they
know you were writing a book yeah
they're kind enough to actually put
together focus groups so like the second
time I went pastor Steve put together
like ten members of the congregation I
sort of sat in a in their you know their
lunch room in the basement and we talked
for an hour about politics and community
and things like that they're people
actually extraordinarily welcoming
that's one of the other things you know
they wanted to talk they feel a lot of
people want to talking about media I
mean just like you did yeah
because they feel locked out I mean that
wasn't there talking about media as I
listen but they feel locked out from the
national media and that frustration I
was a good person to express that
frustration to yeah
were you shocked that they were as
welcoming and friendly I mean it's
almost sounds silly to have to ask that
question but I think a lot of lefties a
lot of progressives actually think that
these are all evil people did it shock
you so let me tell you a story so The
Washington Post did a word cloud I think
about a year or two ago which they as
Democrats what you thought about
Republicans and Republicans what you
thought about Democrats and then they
sort of put a put it up visually
and all the words on both sides were
terribly nasty Democrats thought you
know Republicans were bigoted cheap
selfish racist and that was two years
ago I'm sure they're much worse now
right yeah
so so I sort of challenge myself like I
didn't believe that but I sorta believed
it yeah what were the words though that
Democrats said about Republicans do you
remember that race I'm sorry the other
way around that Republican
I don't remember but they were all on
flattery I think stupid intolerant lid
tired yeah right there's no flake is all
before that right or that whole lingo I
learned that lingo from Breitbart
so I had to admit myself that somewhere
you know deep down I probably had those
home prejudice because they're not
accurate and I sort of carried me with
them even as I was trying to be open
mind and open heart in the journey so
you know it was didn't shock me that
people were people were people and they
cared about the same things I care about
and wanted to talk but you know I also
know that it was preconception busting
if I have to be perfectly honest about
it yeah give me another anecdote or two
of wandering around things that sort of
hit you that became sort of the seminal
moments of this yeah so so I wanted
against or the challenge of what what do
you do to sort of be in the shoes of a
conservative it's not I mean you can
watch Fox and you can read breitbart and
do a lot of different things but how do
you experience it so you know NASCAR
races but one thing I read an article in
The Washington Post
apparently I still worried the
Washington Post and it was it had a
quote from the head of heritage action
energy foundation action who said you
know the people in the cell Accord are
missing the awesomeness of America I
said that's right that's me I've been
the xcel quarter I need to find the
awesomeness America so I knew Tucker
Carlson a little bit and I went to see
Tucker Norrell and I said all right tell
me how to find the awesomeness of
America you should know even though he's
from they say in the South Corridor I am
and he said sort of puzzling then he
started you should go pig hunting in
Texas all right I'll go pig hunting in
Texas so I spent sorry I did that
it's part of you know my challenge I
want to challenge myself an issue that I
didn't know a lot about but I'm sure I
was right and gun control and gun rights
so what was your position at that time
when we started here I'm for all for
virtually every form of gun control
imaginable up to if I could figure out a
way to take everyone's guns I've
probably been for it that's was your
previous position that was a previous
night now we'll get to here and you have
this experience so I went hunting so I
wouldn't pick on the Texas had learned
out you know some people should have a
gun in some shouldn't and I'm on the
shouldn't side because I'm morning
danger but you know it's in the more
than your first time actually holding a
gun my first time holding shoot that I
went to a skeet range in Prince George's
County the week before to test it but
that essentially that experience was the
first time and the morning I ended up
with a three-generation family from
Georgia
Isaac CJ and paps the grandfather and I
end up actually with Isaac who was at
the time eight it was sort of my hunting
companion and so it was sort of he was
the mentor in that because he knew how
to hunt and he was sort of gently guided
me through the hunting process and we
had a great time together and you know
we told stories hunting even though I
didn't have stories of hunting and you
want to tell how he shot the out of
pigs this day and the afternoon I ended
up with what I call sort of a
demographic version of a bar bar joke a
black guy from Houston a former spanic
former soldier and a Serbian immigrant
and me a Jew from Washington we were the
hunting group yeah and we had a great
time we talked about guns and their
community and what their why they cared
about guns and it's a great experience
and that's the call of John Locke the
conservative economist and said all
right convince me why I'm so wrong
they did I mean when you talk to real
experts and you talk to real people and
real experts you better be open to
learning a little bit yeah they're a lot
all right let's pause on economics for a
second so funny as you're describing
this I mean basically you're writing the
the plot when you do the screenplay on
this to city slickers three I mean it's
your Billy Crystal yeah I go pig hunting
this time instead of you know Rassilon
combustion yeah
right right so you have these
experiences you seem to you like the
people did you find any diversity of
thought on that side I mean it sounds
like it was mostly at first about well
they were nice that's that's pretty good
yeah did you see were they all in
lockstep intellectually the way you were
sort of frustrated with that so here's
so yeah I think people live so I think
people lived a conservative bubble - and
tend to gravitate towards each other the
truth and matters I mean but the truth
in matter is most people don't actually
spend a lot of time thinking about these
issues I mean the media is saturated my
hometown though the swamp of washing is
saturated ninety percent of the country
is not spending their time worried about
the details of the tax bill or whether
Jerusalem should be the location for the
American Embassy in Israel or not
they're worried about the community
they're worried about family they're
worried about the Youngstown State
football team more than they are worried
about that and part of the sort of I
think the the fallacy of modern media
and political insider is that the
beliefs that everyone cares about the
same things we do they don't they really
cared about their local issues and their
local in their family matters and that's
you know really what they want to talk
about and you know the the charge like I
hear from a lot of my liberal friends or
progressive friends that that everyone
voted for Trump Barr is you know either
agrees with Trump or is a racist like
Trump or whatever not true I think
people just don't pay attention on the
same levels that I do that you do and
others and I think a lot of the
conversations was I'm sure diversity
thought because most people don't
actually spend a lot of time thinking
about it when you actually talk about
are you forgotten people don't fall
neatly into are you for guns or you
against guns actually tend to gravitate
towards the middle when you actually
start talking about is this a reasonable
gun control idea is this a you know do
you really want to confiscate guns
people gravitate towards the middle in
real life just not in the media world
yeah so let's talk a little bit about
your evolution and so as someone that
was pretty radical in a certain sense on
guns beforehand I mean they were saying
almost get rid of them
yeah now you go out you're hunting pigs
in Texas yeah look an eight-year-old
yeah then what happens so essentially I
came to the conclusion you know
I came not an acolyte of John lot
because that's not not correct that
criticized some of his work in my book
but I was persuaded by sort of the the
effectiveness he so so John Lott is a
it's not a gun rights guy he's a public
safety guy and the challenge he put to
me was explained to me how so many of
these gun control measures that you
believe are fantastic actually would
change things and as I dived with him
and then separately into the data and
there stood that you know how these
things actually work it it actually
taught me one things one is that most of
the things that you know people stand up
for gun control don't actually work
doing the laws themselves ourselves were
the proposals for further restrictions
on gun gun use generally won't have any
impact and secondly I think even more
importantly um people have forgotten
that the murder rate with using guns in
this country has fallen half over the
last 20 years as we've argued over here
about gun control or gun rights we've
actually been extraordinary effective in
terms of driving down gun homicides in
this country has nothing to do with that
debate it has to do with better policing
economic opportunity you know attacks on
drug gangs and things like that there's
actually a lot of learning and if we
really cared about the ultimate outcome
we'd spend a lot more time figuring out
how to do things like Boston did on the
pulling levers program and less about
this argument about whether wait a
minute do you need an assault weapon ban
because that actually has relatively
little effect of any yeah so when people
are talking about guns this is I mean to
me this is one of the ones where we've
really cordoned ourselves off yeah it's
we're almost at the place of ban or
everyone gets a bazooka I definitely
fall more on the side of I strongly
believe in the Second Amendment and I
don't think that the murders that we
have necessarily are gun issues I mean
even the guy to your point about the
laws that the guy last month that shot
the church in Texas yeah it was illegal
for him to get a gun right so there were
laws in place so it's like we can keep
making more laws but that doesn't mean
people won't keep breaking the laws and
that that seems to be the disconnect I
think where the left says well just make
more laws and we can actually whittle
away
and all of this and for me it's like I
don't see how more laws actually resolve
this things I mean actually complicated
so so the Sutherlands bringing church
slaying as you described are was
evocative me because where I went Pig
huntin was about eight miles from from
Gonzales Texas as the crow flies about
thirty minutes thirty miles in 30
minutes by car and that's actually one
of the things is you know you don't have
a cop around the corner you know beat
cop around the corner like you do in
washing you see reminds me of the the
t-shirt I saw a gun shows which is I'd
rather have a gun in my hand than a cop
on the phone but it's you know it's
evocative because it has so much it sort
of bowels up so much of the challenge
which is we clearly have a problem look
we have a you know mass shooting and
more importantly we have urban shootings
every day and we you know even though
we've had successes we still our way we
have far more violent society than other
similar situated countries say in
Western Europe yeah probably I want to
know a little more about that I mean
just Google just how many people are
shot in Chicago this weekend yeah I mean
they keep it running down right and that
has nothing to do with assault weapons
or you know registration laws because
it's almost all handguns and almost all
guns obtainable illegally we've so so so
we have a problem so let's all now
hundra there's a really sort of a
horrible public policy problem but
nothing that we talked about actually
would solve it and you know in
Sutherland Springs if a guy who got his
gun shouldn't have got his gun and then
he was ultimately crowd by a you know a
private citizen who lawfully had a gun
and you know probably stopped a
potentially stop worse killings so it's
complicated issue and I think we because
we're all in our you know arm bubbles
talking to each other we miss the nuance
and don't really try to solve the
problem because it's solvable yeah we've
actually solved in some ways so
obviously you had an evolution on guns
yeah was it just like knocking down
dominoes once once this happened give me
give me a couple of the others that you
evolved done so I what the way I
structured the book is I took a number
of issues which I acknowledged a front I
was an expert on but sort of sense that
I was on the right side of history and I
sort of built the book around that so
guns was one climate change was another
poverty climate change yeah so the
climate change is where I learned to
hate everyone you
I was doing to say no matter what you
say right now yeah we're both gonna get
a tremendous amount of eight and
truthfully probably should I mean the
the you know I learned to hate sort of
the Conservatives who the not deserve
the Republican Party who I think is
diminished itself by ignoring science
that it's awfully clear I've learned to
hate the Democratic Party which is sort
of then taken established science and
then described you know I think policy
results that probably aren't going to be
very effective and often are essentially
go at the the weakest in society the
people who can least afford you know the
the result of higher energy prices or
the shutdown of coal mines I spend time
in Pikeville Kentucky I'll tell you the
world looks a lot different if you're in
Pikeville Kentucky watching the local
coal mines close Appalachia has been an
internal colony in the United States for
a hundred years and you know they found
a reasonable semblance of middle-class
life through coal mining and then to
have sort of the outside power say wait
a minute what you're doing has too much
externalities you're out of business
really a very destructive and thing I'm
complicated because of course it was
probably natural gas that drove a lot of
the coal mines out of business but not
feeling sort of the you know one the
reason people are angry is because they
feel like they've been abandoned by the
political leaders and I think it's
earnest and it's true yeah and Trump
went right to that during the election I
mean he made a major play to that so
when you were talking to some of these
people about climate change yeah
did you feel that now I'm gonna go on
the assumption that most of them you
know didn't believe in it in the
conventional sense but did you find that
they didn't believe in the science if
you brought some scientific information
didn't was it a dismissal of science or
was there something else or did it have
to do with religion and what they
believe the the earth and God is capable
of and and all of that like what was
actually the way of thinking so I think
way most people think around these
things is output peep words and people
about this is my sort of read on which
is I'm getting screwed my community's
getting screwed people are leaving
anyone who can leave Pikeville Kentucky
leaves Pikeville Kentucky I had a job in
a career in the in the coal mine and it
was I wasn't getting rich but I was
having a decent life for me and my
family and it's all gone I'm getting
screwed I think once you recognize that
everything else sort of
behind that so it's you know this
government's fault it's Sciences fault I
don't think I think people are angry and
then they can reason anything behind
that and I think that's interesting so
it's sort of a visceral reaction because
their day-to-day life having nothing to
do with the science so for example like
when Hillary Clinton during the campaign
said something about closing down all
the coal mines yeah even if you gave
them the greatest scientific study in
front of their face you know with with
rock proof you know lockbox proof
yeah well it's irrelevant well I mean
look the the crumbs victory is is is
there a number of reasons from one but
one is you know doing better among the
white working-class whites without a
college degree you wanted by 39%
it's extraordinary Matt and you look at
the white working-class sort of a big
forty forty percent of the country I
mean and you know income down life
expectancy down opioid addiction up
belief in the future sort of you know
what do you think your will your kids
have a better life than you way down
that's a group of people are a thirty
year losing streak I mean that's the
story of a big chunk of America and a
lot follows from that politics fog
pockets doesn't drive that politics
follows from that you know I remember
taking I think it was a ap history class
in eighth grade
either seventh or eighth grade and I
remember the teacher telling us that we
were gonna be the first generation to
not do as well as our parents and I
remember the way that stuck with me like
what it felt like like the weight of the
world what a horrible thing like you
know I grew up we were fine but I wanted
I wanted to be more or better or have
you know whatever it whatever that means
I just over think it's just such a
depressing thing to have to hear yeah
that your kids are gonna have it worse
than you are you as the kid you're gonna
have it worse than then your parents
like it's it's so reverse of the way the
American Dream is supposed to work yes
um I'm older than you so I probably
heard it you know more years than I care
to mention the you and but people didn't
say that I mean there was a there's an
unstated or maybe it's stated belief
that every generation will be wealthier
taller
you know better-looking than their
parents that will have it better and
that's what your parents I'm working for
that my son Nate
have a better life and that's sort of a
core of the American Dream and to see
and it's not just the white
working-class there are other parts of
the country and it just happened beware
I spent time with her in this book see
parts of the country proven that that
American Dream is not right is a painful
indictment of our system and you know on
the left side that's you know that's
sort of the attack on the 1% but on the
right side its belief that you know
government Society has left us behind
and the establishment has forgotten us
for their own own good and Donald Trump
as you said went right into that and won
that argument yes so on the on the
climate change one so how do you resolve
those two things then so if you have
people that are just dealing with the
immediacy of their lives their jobs
their family and then you have science
that seems to be settled yeah but those
things cannot come together because
these people have to worry about their
lives now not you know the planet and
100 years or whatever yeah and at the
same time what you were saying is that
the Democrats often their policies
related to this hurt those people the
most because you raise costs for
alternative energy and all that do it
well so how did you evolve on this like
where do you find yourself in this
discussion now so I think I've become
more so I haven't come more skeptical
about the science I don't I haven't no
no not at all but I've come more
skeptical about the government's
solutions to the problem and the belief
that government by Fiat is the right way
to deal with this and so I've come to
believe that I mean if you actually look
at how other governments have dealt with
it often badly like in Germany I mean
we've the no one talks about the fact
that we're actually doing better in the
US on climate change because of the
natural gas revolution we're here in LA
right now I mean if you walk outside
with the plastic bag they'll shoot you
we have cops on everything right right
snipers will take you it's a dangerous
place you know that the solutions that
are offered you know some global
solutions aren't necessarily the best
ones I mean the things that have
actually been effective in the US are
thing I mean fracking in the natural gas
explosion figuratively not literally
that's what sadly we clipped and that's
actually you know what that's what's
driven coal out of business that's
what's actually driven down the the
carbon curb in the United States not
government Fiat the innovation of the
electric car market often driven by
government subsidy so let's recognize
that but those it's the innovations of
places like Tesla I think whole
prospects for the future and
government's job should be not to do it
by Fiat but actually to encourage
innovation and change and I just been
become skeptical too or it's sort of you
know the view that we have to do it in
one way because those one ways don't
often work and you know that's made me
skeptical actually towards both sides um
I've actually come back to say you know
people ask me so I I was a Democrat I
registered as a Republican for the year
yeah I was gonna commit to the to the
bit you know and I didn't know what what
happened when I came back and when I
came back I registered we registered as
an independent and actually think you
know I think both parties are kind of
selling us out yeah
and that there's actually much more
possibility in in a dirty word which is
compromise
yeah even that choice though of which
way you're gonna register although I'm a
big states rights guy it creates a
problem because in some states you then
can't vote in primaries sure which is an
inherent problem and I would always
leave that to the states but not
everyone has that luxury in states that
doesn't don't allow you to do that well
I tell people I now have the most
useless vote in America I live in oh
yeah Washington say right so it's only
gonna be the Democrats who get elected
I don't even vote in the Democratic
primary so my vote is pretty useless
what does it tell you that that DC area
is so ideologically one way and that way
at the moment has is in direct conflict
with the way that the administration is
yeah like how did the all the apparatus
around DC is it just because generally
speaking Democrats and left want bigger
government and everyone there is working
from the for the government yeah it's an
interesting question which I haven't
given entirely entire thoughts to but I
think look I think I would say two
things one which is naturally I think
people who believe in government the
effectiveness of government
gravitate towards Washington see it
makes sense right I mean just from a
from a life you know a like gold
perspective if you believe in government
and the power to government to solve
problems sure you want to be in
Washington see that's a place we call
city also pretty hard to get fired from
the government so if you're pretty inept
at your job it's a good place they need
to the but I think the other thing is I
mean we've actually done pretty good and
I mean if so I think it's asking
yourself you're conservative now you
want to listen you want to move to
Washington see the place that you
believe is a swamp where you know
everyone around you is going to think
differently from you and so we're now
self segregated I mean people the
Conservatives move one area Democrats
move another and you can even see it in
a micro level within DC the D crater DC
area but it like in Texas you know if
you're liberal or movie Texas where do
you go Austin right and then you got the
you know then conservers moved to the
rural error it's Dallas and so I mean
it's so very interesting in segregation
that we've gone it's called the big sort
and it's real yeah all right so guns
climate change give me one other so I
spent a lot of time on poverty program
so you know I'm a born in 1963 grew up
in a sort of Roosevelt
Democrat household believe it in the
great deal in the Great Society and I
sort of wanted to dive into poverty
programs in their effectiveness
believing that you know society's
obligation to make opportunity for those
who who need it most and I came away I
think you know skeptical still believing
in sort of the importance of that
principle but skeptical about I think
sort of established nostrums on the
right on the left about the
effectiveness of poverty programs we
spend a trillion dollars a year even
people or people don't actually believe
that they're effective right no one
actually this country believes they're
effective and yet government spending on
poverty programs broadly defined has
gone up every year through Democrat and
Republican administrations alike every
year since the Great Society in 1968 or
whatever really started 50 years ago
enough and the poverty level hasn't
changed a bit
so how much of that do you think is just
lazy thinking like getting it away from
politics for a second it's just always
easy
be like there's a problem throw more
money there it's a problem throw away
and then or it just sounds bad there's a
problem we're gonna take money away like
that just sounds evil you know but so
it's not even political per se it's just
it's just not clearly thinking about the
issue itself yeah so I think I think
there so I think there's to that which
is guess what these things are hard I
mean there's a sighs ability to sort of
solve these things approve it and you
know a long time and time again
throughout history the second thing is I
think we have a Cecily short-term memory
we tend to look at things in almost like
monthly slices without looking at the
long-term history of things um so I
think you know the idea of we should put
less money into poverty programs or
three think them doesn't make sense you
know on a day to day basis but if you
look at it over 50 years you probably
start thinking maybe we need to rethink
some of these things and I sort of had
this thought again when you know when
when President Trump rolled back the the
Bears year's National Monument whether
you agree with it not I mean that sort
of the the diction from the
environmental community that this is a
destruction of of the American landscape
and you know betrayal of our cultural
and environmental heritage well you know
that didn't exist
the Bears year didn't exist you know 10
months ago you know we still actually
have a bigger dedication of land than we
did a year ago
we need to think things in a little bit
broader context before we sort of run to
our battlements and start accusing the
other people of being evil which is what
we do every day yeah so it's interesting
to me although you're saying Republican
like me and I do want to find out the
exact moment you said all right on a
Republican a lot of what you're saying
here really sounds very libertarian now
I understand you can there's a
libertarian wing of the Republican Party
but basically what you're saying is you
your feelings on most of these issues
didn't change that much
but at every where the rubber met the
road every time you realize that the
government wasn't the answer that
strikes me as a really libertarian way
of thinking yeah I like to think about
it so in the book I describe myself as
being part of the muddled middle because
I see sort of value MSC's still value in
government solutions and I still think
Society has an obligation to care for
the the people who live in the shadow
the people you know the people in
Pikesville Kentucky
need our help they don't need our
lectures on the evils of cult they need
our help
I don't know if there's a sort of a
principled belief other than sort of the
notion that a lot of the solutions that
we talked about and defend everyday have
proven not to work and we really owe
ourselves too little to rethink a lot of
these things yeah and unfortunately
people don't seem to be very good at
that so when did you actually say
finally did you wake up one morning and
go oh my god I've been doing this for a
year I'm one of them but I'm not so so
in the end you know so I you know I'm
one of them so Republican like like me
as you know a little bit of take on
black like me that yeah were in that
case a journalist donned a disguise to
be experienced what it's like to be
black so I was you know in my own small
way trying to experience what it was
like to be Republican and when I
finished you know I you know I said do I
really want to be I mean in another year
I might have very much thought that I
would be a Republican because as you say
a lot of things I learned along the way
not a big fan of Donald Trump in sort of
the carnival atmosphere of Republican
Party that couldn't stay there I didn't
feel at home in the Democratic Party
either so I think I'm home being
independent you know and finding ideas I
like on both sides and disliking a lot
of people and a lot of you know a lot of
the political apparatuses on the
extremes do you think a sensible middle
can actually hold I mean it's one of the
things that I've been talking about for
a long time there is this sort of new
center developing that there's the
disaffected liberals the people who
realize that your government can't do
everything yeah there's the certain
amount of people who don't like the odd
control that the right has related to
religion and a few other things but
there is this new center of basically
people who are pro freedom yeah my fear
is that I don't know if we can really
hold for that long we're building it now
there's a you know this and and so many
of the conversations I have around that
yeah but that ultimately because we're
going to be nipped off by both sides we
may not have enough staying power I'm
gonna keep trying for it yeah I think
I'm with you so I think it's you know I
think it's early so one interesting sort
of political dynamics is the rise
the independence so people don't realize
that indepence an hour 42% people who
identify as in depends 42 percent of the
country far more than Republicans or
Democrats and a lot more than there were
15 years ago and that I think is because
some people are thinking a little bit
differently I think it's because some
people are really Democrats and
Republicans but are embarrassed by their
parties and I think then there are
people in there who you know really
don't know what they're for or against
but it is interesting to me that there
is that growth of people who are saying
more and more you know what I don't
trust the party even if I vote for them
lockstep I don't trust the you know one
side of the other I don't like the way
that going about doing their business
there's got to be a different way and
that's the rise of the depends whether
they coalesce into a political movement
or force changes in in politics I don't
know but there's something interesting
going on so it's interesting to me that
you said the the carnival atmosphere
around Trump because certainly there is
a carnival atmosphere there's no doubt
the tweet and all of that yeah but in
terms of the things that he's talking
about he's actually doing yeah it does
kind of line up with a lot of the things
that you learned about it right I mean I
think I read the other day that for
every one regulation that they've passed
now they've knocked away 17 he basically
has been for smaller government and tax
cuts and trying to rethink some of these
things so is that it's really you're
hung up on the on the carnival portion
look I wish we had Thomas Jefferson
again yeah well Jefferson monument near
your house India that's the stuff that I
would rather have these days so so
Trump's really interesting I mean he in
some ways he's run a very conventional
conservative Republican government you
know the tax bill is varakin standard
Republican playbook Obamacare
you know appointments the Supreme Court
I mean a lot of things actually straight
from the Mitch McConnell playbook the
thing I object to and I think it's real
so I mean so I think the tweets are not
just sort of a carnal atmosphere without
consequences I think a lot of people are
willing to say well that's just drunk
being Trump it's in just him I think he
is destructive of democratic
institutions that matter I mean there's
a tax on the press I'm not a I'm not the
person who stands up for the presses you
know how 2%
at his tracks attacks on the press I
think hurt his tax on the judiciary his
attacks on the Independence of the
Justice Department and the FBI
investigation I think those are all
destructive of public's faith
institutions which are weak anyway I
think that's really bad for president
and that's independent of policy that's
Donald Trump being at rumpus not being a
conservative yeah yeah so where does
this all right what's next now how do we
get some of this coalesce and get some
people to think clearly about these
issues and realize that the Republican
down the road is not your enemy and the
Democrat is not the little tart in the
rest yeah I think it's actually a really
interesting which I don't have a good
bottle of answer I'm gonna keep talking
about and writing about that's what I
can do that might be the end all right
there I'm interested actually I mean
there there are some structural things
that matter I think the Supreme Court
case on gerrymandering actually matters
a lot is one of things that has happened
is we have what's called landslide
counties 20 County in which one party
essentially controls it by wins the
election by 20% or more basically it's a
one-party County ten years ago we had
1,100 those counties this past election
we had 2500 of them we've essentially
forced it away that one party its
one-party rule in most parts to the
United States and when that happens well
then you don't talk to each other you
don't compromise you'll need to and
you're essentially fighting whatever
whatever wing of the two wings of the
party are fighting each other that's
what the pockets are that's destructive
and I think the Supreme Court has a
once-in-a you know lifetime opportunity
to start pushing us backwards towards a
more balanced political environment yeah
I need to do a show on gerrymandering
because it really is one of the most
important especially it is if you care
about local politics which is we're
really where it matters yeah it's one of
most important things it's just one of
those topics that never gets traction
you know free it's not sexy people right
people look at a map and they're going
oh you're gonna shift this line here and
it's like nobody gets riled up about
that unfortunately well but it goes to
the S I mean it really goes the essence
of which is political dialogue I mean
you know just like Congress but
ultimately you know it's job is to
compromise and to find ways solutions
that enough you know half the people who
can get behind and right now it's only
the Republicans literally you have the
Democrats sitting there saying I'm gonna
vote no on everything and the
Republicans trying to hold on to the you
know their
their majority that's one-party rule
that's not the two-party system that I
know and we need and until we actually
sort of structurally figure that out you
know I'll write a nice book hopefully it
sells books the other things won't
change I think in a meaningful way
yeah as a general rule at this point I I
sense you'd be for scaling back all of
this just stop giving these people so
much power right these people being
being government just in general that
they just shouldn't have as much power
if their solutions aren't really working
yeah then why should they have that much
power so it's it's yeah I mean I think
there's a I think I wouldn't put that
way I think is the reason I'm leaving
you with the claim in a little bit is
because you're badgering the witness
slightly because I find I know there's
so many people that are feeling what you
feel here that I've realized that you
know lefties that realized okay these
aren't horrible people they have a
different set of problems they're a
different set of beliefs well then what
what is the the only answer is that the
government should just let us live and
let live more in my estimation so that's
why I'm I think the government should be
obligated so perhaps we'll do this in a
year from now and notice that I think
the you know for me the thing I'm
skeptical about is not ultimately the
it's a power without results and so much
of which I think I've learned over the
years not only this book but my first
book which is about sort of terrible
programs which are usually funded by the
government is that we continue to
perpetuate programs and projects and
spending that has no provable results
they sound good the problems are hard
and what we keep doing is we keep
layering one thing on top of the other
so we have as large and wealthy and
effective government and I think that's
what we're we're at today and part of
the reason for our disconnects yeah I'm
curious what was it like in your bubble
once the book came out and you are on
television and the internet talking
about these things and go these guys
aren't so bad had had your bubble treat
you it's mixed so it's mixed I'll tell
you sort of three different reactions
two of which one of which gives me hope
as I said one was my my ten-year-old son
booing me on television because you know
he's grown up and in that mascara and
what Democrats are right conservers
wrong it's actually a phrase from a
conservative talk show called the will
calm locale majority which those we're
right they're wrong that's the end of
the story and so many people actually
believe that yeah not on the
conservative side liberal side both
sides I got attacked on social media by
a lot of people who wanted to call me
you know I must be a racist or hey gays
or Benedict Arnold all people none of
them would actually read my book having
fun judging a book by it's cover so
there's a lot of that it's dispiriting
and makes me want to chuck my phone out
the window and I think that's probably
been the biggest reaction but there's
been enough people read it and said you
know what I like where you're coming
from I don't necessarily think that
place we need to work our way out and
that's conservative and Republican
conservatives and liberals alike or
these Democrats and Republicans alike
and I think there's enough there to give
me a little sense of encouragement yeah
well listen I I like talking to anyone
that is on a journey of trying to figure
something out and not pretending they
have all the answers I think that seems
to be the key to this whole thing you're
not sitting here pretending that you've
got all the answers well you're gonna
keep trying to figure it out yeah it's
nice right I mean it sort of feels
freeing it away yeah I'm happy to admit
like some of the things I say in the
book probably wrong and I'm happy to be
proven wrong
I think the none of us can be expert in
all the issues but we all sort of
inherently believe that our side is
right they're wrong how do we how do we
know that if we don't haven't explored
those issues and none of the time and
freedom to do that that's why we
shouldn't just immediately assume our
colleagues or units or our fraternity is
right and they're wrong should be
listening to everyone and making it up
you know independent judgments it's been
a pleasure chatting with you we're going
to put a link to the book and get any
comments section right down below and
for more on can you can follow them on
Twitter at Ken P Stern
you
[Music]